[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه وهو موضوعها اليوم استكمال لموضوع
الحلقه الماضيه الذي يتلخص تحت هذا السؤال
حضاره الجزيره العربيه او حضارات الجزيره
العربيه لان مر بها اكثر من حضاره في اكثر
من اتجاه هل هي حضارات مغلقه على ذاتها لم
تقبل البته انت تاثر باي مؤثر خارجي ولا
ان تصدر هي مؤثراتها مؤثراتها الخاصه الى
الخارج او ان الامر كان عكس ذلك وكان يعكس
كما قال ضيفنا في الحلقه الاولى ثقه وقوه
وابداع ابن الجزيره العربيه حيث انه كان
قادرا على التعامل عبر قرون وقرون طويله
مع موضوع التجاره لان الجزيره العربي كانت
مركز التجاره العالميه ولم تكون مجرد مجرد
ممر للقوافل كما قال ضيفنا في الحلقه
الاولى وضيفنا حتى لا ابدا اتحدث عنه بشكل
غائب هو همم البروفيسور الدكتور سليمان
ذيب استاذ من الاثار السعوديه واللغات
العربيه القديمه والمستشاره العلمي في
مركز الملك فيصل ويراس ايضا حاليا
بعثات للتنقيب وهو هو هو يعني في الميدان
العملي والنظري ايضا في حياك الله دكتور
سليمان في الحلقه الماضيه تحدثنا او
استعرضنا همم ملامح من الحضارات الموجوده
في الجزيره العربيه من شرقها او من جنوبها
الى شمالها ومن شرق الى غربها وقسمت انت
الحضارات في الجزيره العربيه الى النوعين
نوع منغلق على نفسه ومقله ومثلث حضاره
قتبان ونوع كان منفتح بشكل كوزمو بوليتا
او مدينه مفتوحه وكان ابرز مثال لديك
حضاره ديدان في العلا وحضاره الانباط حيث
كانت فيها كل اللغات عثر عليها مكتوبه في
الجبال من اللغات الجنوبيه والشمال وحتى
الخارجيه اليونانيه والاغريقيه وما الى
ذلك لكن نمط الغالب يبدو كان هو الحضارات
المنفتحه وايضا ضربت مثلا بان التجاره لم
مجر مجرد ممر بل كانت همم
يعني عمليه تفاعليه هل كان في مح- اذكرنا
ابرز المحطات التجاريه العالميه في
الجزيره العربيه عبر القرون يعني
المراكز ليست محطه
الحضريه الحقيقه في الجزيره العربيه كثيره
جدا ومتعدده يعني اذا اخذنا مثلا معظم مدن
وعواصم جنوب الجزيره العربيه همم ثم نعرج
الى منطقه نجران ثم ندخل الى وسط الجزيره
العربيه نجد الفاو ونجد الافلام والخارج
في وسط الجزء العربيه ثم ننتقل الى همم
الى الشمال الى عديده جدا همم منطقه جبه
في حائل ادو- ادوماته اللي هجمت دومه
الجندل تيما همم
والعلا وديدان في غرب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وذلك في شرقها نجد ايضا همم ساج وغيرها من
المواقع اللي تعود الى الفتره الع نبدا
الفتره دلمون اول حتى لفترات الاسلاميه
فهي متعدده كثيره جدا كما قلنا وكان نقول
دائما الجزيره العربيه هي فسيفساء في
جغرافيتها وفي بيئتها وفي ثقافتها وفي
عاداتها وفي تقاليدها هذه الفسيفساء يجب
ان تظهر على السطح ويجب ان يعرف لسانها
بانه يفترض به ان يستفيد ويستغل هذه
الامكانيات لا ان يتحجر في فكر معين او في
منهج معين او في القبيل ويتناسى بان
اجداده كان لهم دور كبير حتى الفتره
الاسلاميه عندما خرج همم خرجت الجحافر
الجيوش من هذه المنطقه من هذه الجزيره
انتقلوا الى جميع انحاء العالم ناشرين هذا
الدين الاسلامي منها الجزيره هذه التي
همم الحضارات الخارجيه هل نضرب امثله
محدده ما هي ابرز الحضارات الخارجيه اللي
كانت على اتصال مع الجزيره العربيه اما
بسبب التجاره او بسبب او بسبب الثقافه
والدين احيانا الحقيقه حضارات المحيطه
كلها كل الجزيره العربيه احتكا ثقافيه
وتجاريا وحضاريا مع الحضارات الموجوده في
ااه بلاد الرافدين مع الحضارات الموجوده
في سوريا الكبرى سوريا الكبرى اللي هي من
سوريا الحاليه الى لبنان مع الحضارات في
مصر الفرعونيه
ايضا مع الحضارات التلت تلك الحضارات حتى
وصلت الى الحضاره الرومانيه الى ما هي
قبيله الاسلام وبعد قبيل الميلاد ثم بعد
الميلاد ايضا احتكا بها العرب واستفادوا
منها الفتره المظلمه الحقيقه في الجزيره
العربيه هي تعود الى القرن القرن الثاني
او نقول لقرن الرابع تقريبا الرابع الى
سابع ميلادي هذه اللي عانت فيه الجزء
العربيه لانه لم يكن فيها حكم سياسي ثابت
بعد سقطت المملكه النبطيه وهي قبل الاسلام
بقليل هذه الفتره التي
يفسر انه سرعه انت الاسلام
ملعقه فراغ يعني كانه تهيا تهيؤ للشريعه
للدين الاسلامي الحمد لله رب العالمين
الذي الله سبحانه وتعالى فضل مكه المكرمه
غير الغير مجاوره قصدي البعيده مثلا
الصينيه او الهنديه هل لها اثار كمان
في تلك الازمنه انه في تاجر صيني او هندي
يدخل من نجران من بوابه نجران الجنوبيه
البحر او من البحر مثلا من الطريق البحري
ويعالج امور تجارته بما يعني ذلك من
علاقات مع العناصر المحليه والسكان
المحليه هل هذا الصوره صحيح
بمنعه غير القتباني الاجنبي الله يتعامل
موجود هذا همم هذا النوع من الت كانت
الممالك في جنوب الجزء العربيه تاخذ او في
شرقها شرق الجزيره تاخذ البضائع من التاجر
الصيني من التاجر الهندي من المنتج الهندي
والصيني ثم تصدر عن طريقها الى سوريا والى
العراق والى مصر حلقه وصل رئيس الى اوروبا
انا هي كانت حصلت وصل وفي حلقه وصل لا شك
لكن كانت ايضا منتجه يعني على سبيل المثال
همم لو وجدنا الفخار التيمائي او الفخار
النبطي هذه هذا انواع من الفخار المتميز
طلعت على الفخار التي مائي له يعود 3000
سنه قبل الميلاد واستمر استخدامه من 700
قبل الميلاد يعني في تعقيدات تحتاج انك
تقوم باعدادها بطريقه همم تبغى همم شخص
متفرغ شخص مبدع حتى يستطيع ان يرسم على كل
قطعه فخاريه هذا الرسم الموجود وهذه
الرسوم الهندسيه او النباتيه او الحيوانيه
او الادبيه الموجوده على هذه الجزر نجدها
نجدها اليوم
تخيل انه في همم في نقش من النقوش
الموجوده عندنا في ديداء في ديدان ان همم
احد همم المكعبات رسمه يعني صممه صممه مش
رسمه عفوا سممه شخص وقام بتنفيذي شخص اخر
مكتوب اسمه فلان صمم هذا الشكل وفلان يعني
قامت
بتاديه هذا الشكل واخراجك منتج فالف
الجزيره العربيه همم يعني همم هي لا شك
كانت يغلب عليها طابع التواصل الحضاري
ونقل همم البضائع وغيرها لكنها ايضا كانت
يعني ترجع منتجاتها لا شك في ذلك ولو لم
تكن كذلك لما انتجت هذا الكلام الكبير من
اللغات والكتابات التي انتشرت في جميع
انحاء العالم فيما بعد كسر خط يسمودي على
سبيل المثال التي تجده في سوريا وفي
العراق وفي مصر وتجد ايضا في ايطاليا وفي
اليونان
هل كان التاجر العربي
في هذه المناطق مش فقط يستقبل الحركه
التجاره او يصدر بعض بضائع المحليه لا هو
بنفسه ينشا محطات تجاريه في الخارج
ينقل معه ثقافتهم الى مصر الى سوريا
الكبرى الى احد الانباط في عند النقش وجود
معبد موجود في اليونان في اليونان
مما يعني المعبد هذه لماذا يقام لانه فيه
في تكرار للناس اللي يجون حتى يمارسوا
طقوسم الدينيه في هذا المعبد او في هذا
المسجد يمارس طقوسم الدينيه في معناته في
في حركات تجاريه والعلاقات ما بين الانباط
وروما علاقات قويه جدا يعني احيانا طبعا
فيها نوع من التبعيه لكنها ايضا فيها نوع
من همم
تبين حقيقه دور
الثقافي يعني عند الانباط الحقيقي
موجوده كلها في حضارات حضارات قصدي يعني
مجتمعات ومراكز حضاريه لها احتكاك كبير
جدا مع المناطق خارج الجزيره العربيه
وداخلها ال- ال- هي المشكله عندنا يعني من
انه الناس لا لا يتصورون انه الجزيره
العربيه بصحرائها اليوم انها كان انتجت
مثل هذا المنتج وهذا الخطا اللي لقائنا
فيه طبعا نحن في اقسام في تخصص الاثار لم
يعطي هذه الاثار حقها وفي نفس الوقت نحتاج
الى دعم كبير جدا حتى نستطيع ان نبرز
الانسان العادي حتى لما اقول العادي اللي
عنده فضول في ناس مو لازم يصير متخصص بس
لديه فضول يتعرف على الارث الحضاري القديم
الجزيره العربيه لا يجد بغيته الكافيه في
سواء في المحتوى انا رجل في الاعلام اقول
لك حتى في الاعلام عندنا ما تجد الجرعه
الكافيه تجد اشياء اجتهادات يعني لا تشمل
ولا تغني من جوه ما تجد ماده علميه
متتابعه ومتواتره يوتيوب في افلام وثائقيه
الى اخره وايضا لا ادري لا اريد ان اظلم
بس ما ادري كيف تقييمك العالم المتاحف
المفتوح للجمهور وليس المتخصصين يجيوا
يتعرف على هالطوار او الجدار الحضاري كما
قلت همم والله المتاحف الحقيقه يعني يحمل
شجون كثيره جدا همم شيخنا العزيز لانه نحن
بحاجه المراه والمسرح سجون كبيره عشان ما
اقاطعك بعطيك فرصه لان ده امر الوقت الان
بعد الفاصل نكمل الاجابه في هذه وعند حسره
الدكتور همم سليمان التي نتمنى ان لا تطول
كثيرا بعد الفاصل نكمل النقاش حول هذا
الامر فلا تذهب
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد
هل يوجد حضاره مغلقه في الجزيره العربيه
عبر الاف والالاف السنين ام هي حضاره
بطبيعتها منفتحه تاخذ وتعطي تعثر وتتاثر
هذا كان نقاشنا مع الدكتور سليمان ذياب
عالم الاثار السعوديه والاستاذ المعروف في
مجاله وصل به النقاش الى ان انا سالت يعني
انه هو استعرض حقيقه استعراض جميل جدا
اييه متنوع رهيب يعني لفت انتباه انه كان
يقول في معبد نبطي نبطي يعني ربع يعني
شمال غرب الجزيره العربيه موجود كان في
اليونان مما يعني وين وصلت الحضاره
العربيه في تلك الازمه لو مع ذلك همم
الكثير ومنهم المحبين او الهواتف مثل
محدثكم الفقير ربما لا يجد الماده الكافيه
في اليوتيوب في الافلام الوثائقيه حتى في
الدراما التي تغني هذا هذا الموضوع حق
الاغماء وليس مجرد اجتهادات وشخبطات وهو
ضرب مثل
بتوع المتاحف ان المتاحف غرضها ان تكون
تمنح فرصه للزائر ان يتعرف بصوره مرتبه
وعلميه ومشوقه الى هذه الحضارات وتحسر
وتاوه عند هذه النقطه ههه نريد
ان المتحف والمسرح الذي تقام عليه قطعه
اثريه مهما مهما جبت لكم بارسل والممثلين
حتى يقوموا بدورهم اذا لم تضع المسرح تقام
فيه المسرحيه فلن يقابل فلن يكون اي معنى
للمسرح اذا ما بنيت المدرسه حتى تعلم فيها
الطالب وتعلم فيها الطالب فلا معنى
للدراسه اذا ما بنيت المستشفى تعالج فيها
طبيب فما لا فلا معنى الحقيقه سوماتون
المرضى ولم تجب منكانا لتعالج فيه انا ارى
انه المتحف ومسرح الاثار هو المكان الذي
توضع فيه الاثار مما يؤسف له طبعا بطبيعه
الحال لانه في سنوات الاخيره تم بفصل
المتاحف عن الاثار
وهذا في تصور الشخصي خطا كبير ارجو اتمنى
من المسؤولين في وزاره الثقافه تدارك لا
يعني هذا باننا نترك المتاحف الاخرى ذات
ذات الاهتمام غير اثار نتركها ونقول ان
داعي لا بالعكس نحن نريد ان تكون هيئه
المتاحف هيئه المتاحف مسؤوله مباشره عن كل
ما له علاقه كل ما له ليس له علاقه
بالاثار يعني الفنون على سبيل المثال
المحليه ال- ال- الفضاء السيارات وتطورها
كل ماله اتصال كل شيء هذه كنت هي تابعه
لها لكن الاثار المتاحه في الاثريه يجب ان
تكون تحته تحت نطاق وتحت مظله الاثار لان
هي هو مسرحها انا لما الاثار لما يروح
ينقب ويطلع القطع الاثري اين يذهب بها
لازم يذهب بها الى المدح بعد الترميد
ترى انه المفروض يتم نقلها الى مكان مخصص
لان متميزه
هذه الصخره بها الكثير من من المعلومات
بكثير من الاشياء التي تعطي الراقي في
معرفه شيء يعني يسموديين بطريقه مباشره
يعني كل ما تجد عن خطوط الثموديه تجده في
هذه الصخره بشكل غريب جدا الحقيقه كانه
الثمود الحائلي قال لاعضاء التدريس في
العالم العربي انظروا هذه اللوحه مدرسوها
لطلابكم هذه بتغنيكم عن ثلاثه اربعه كتب
او وراء اربع صفحات لذلك انا ارى الحقيقه
لن يود يعود الى المتاحف واهميه الحقيقه
اعاده النظر بانه يجب فصل
المتاحف الاثريه واي عاداتها الى الاثار
لان الاثار لا توضع في المخازن الا
للدراسه او للترميم لكن يجب ان توضع في
المتاحف وهذا الفصل بين هذين القطاعين مع
تقديري وكامل احترامي لمن اتخذ هذا القرار
هذا شيء يؤدي الى تاخر ان نبرز الانجازات
الحضاريه للناس لانه هاتين هاتين مختلفتين
هات يعني
لا هيئه الاثار وهيئه المتاحف وتتصاد يعني
تتصاد امانه يعني في تصادم بينها بين
بينهما لمصالحهم هذا الخاصه فلذلك ارى
الحقيقه همم يعني ضروره اعاده هذا المسرح
الى الاثار
الاثرين لانه لو رحنا الى المتاحف
الاقليميه التي بنيت في عهد الدكتور عبد
الله المصري الله يذكره بالخير ويمسيه
بالخير ادى الدوره هذه لانها كانت حافضا
ليست مخزنه ولكنها كانت الحقيقه مراه
لاثار كل منطقه موجوده ما امل ان هذا يعود
مره اخرى لا نفرط بهذا النجاح ثم نعود
الناس تتقدم الى الامام لا ترجع الى
الوراء نحن مع الاسف يعني لا اقول رجعنا
الى الوراء ولكننا خلقنا مشكله يفترض ان
لا تخلق طيب هذه نقطه مهمه انا احببت انه
تاخذ وقتك فيها لان فعلا همم يعني همم
راعي من رجل متخصص لكن حول المتاحف ثم
انطلق
قريبا منه المتحف اللي اذا فتح للببلك
للزوار للعامه
وللمتذوقين يرتقي بثقافتهم جدي هل الكلام
اللي نقوله على الطاوله هذا هو يروح
يشوفوا راي العين يمكن ناس ما تطيق سماء
الكلام بس لما يروح من شرائح عمريه مختلفه
وشرائح ذهنيه مختلفه يجد هالكلام اللي
نقوله مثلا نقش لاتيني يوناني يجد جلب من
من العلا خلاص قدام عيني يمكن يلبسه محتاج
تنظير يعني في الموضوع هذا
المتحف يا سيدي هو في الواقع تثقيفي تربوي
تعليمي يعني همم
تربوي يربي الانسان يدخل اليه لانه انت
تشوف الحضارات هذه كلها وتشوف هذه الاشياء
كيف ادت ايه تتربى من خلالها يرتقي فكرك
هذا اذا اعطي المتاحف لمن يستطيع ان
يديرها لكن اذا اعطي للناس لا يستطيع ان
يديره
اثارنا نحن في الجزيره العربيه لما اقول
الجزيره العربيه اقصد حتى اليمن والبلدان
الخليج والاخره هذه ارضنا كلها ارضيه
واحده كم اللي موجود منها خارج خارج
الجزيره العربيه في المتاحف الاجنبيه
صعب اني اقول لك لكن عادات كبيره جدا
كثير
لكن يفترض فينا نحن في العالم العربي سواء
كان من اليمن او من دول الخليج العربي او
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان ابني
متاحفنا بانفسنا وان تكون متاحف ان
التثقيفيه تنوريه تعليميه كل شيء ليش لان
ولا يجب ان نحصرها فقط في اثار ان احنا
يجب ان يجب لا تقل متحف الوطني في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
يجب ان يدخل ال- ال- المواطن وغير المواطن
لهذا المتحف ويرى حضاره
على فقط
الاثار السعوديه اثار في الجزء العربيه
دكتوره الان هل هل ما شاء الله العرض
الرائع على مدى حلقتين للتنوع المثير
للدهشه في الجزيره العربيه والانفتاح ايضا
وبنفس الوقت الحفاظ والاعتزاز بالهويه
لماذا البعض يضيق ذرعا بذلك رغم ان حتى
غير الحديث العلم انا مثلا همم
وجدت في وثائق الرؤيا رؤيه 20 30 تحت
عنوان الثقافه والناس هذا الناس تمتاز
الحياه السعوديه بالتنوع الاجتماعي الذي
يشكل ثراء همم ساهم ثراء ثقافيه ساهم في
رسم هويه غنيه لسكان المملكه ثم اخر تنفرد
مناطق السعوديه اللي هي 13 منطقه بلا
هجاتها وعاداتها وتقاليدها ومطبخها الى
اخرها هو هذا التنوع هو مصدر قوه وليس
مصدر ضعيفه
اللي كتب هذا الكلام يعي تماما بانه بانه
يتكلم عن التاريخ القديم التاريخ القديم
في الجزيره العربيه في تنوع ثقافه في تنوع
حضاري تنوع لغه وتنوع في اللهجات هو نفسه
ما تعيش والمملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم
التي تغطي اكثر من اثنين مليون كم مربع
لذلك الحقيقه همم
هذا اللي كتب هذا الكلام الحقيقه يعني فتح
لنا باب على ضروره الحقيقه الاهتمام بهذه
الثقافات بهذا التراث الموجود عندنا في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والاثار
الموجوده فيها وعندنا حقيقه مثال بسيطه لو
سمحت يعني اقوله اللي عندنا في مركز الملك
فيصل الان نقوم بمشروع الحقيقه اسمه
المرويه العربيه وهذه المرويه العربيه
اساسا طنطلق الحقيقه لاعطاء الشعوب او
القبائل العرب ان يقول العرب في الجزء
العربيه حقهم الذي لا نريد ان نقول هضم
لكن بطريقه اكثر اكثر يعني ملامسه للواقع
واكثر انفته على الاخر لذلك هذا المشروع
الحقيقي اذا كتب له النجاح سوف يعطي
الحقيقه دفعه قويه جدا
يعني
مرويه العربيه يعني شفويه العربيه هو
الحديث من خلال محاضرات ومن خلال ورش عمل
ومن خلال كتب ومن خلال الاقامه مشاريع
ضخمه من اجل تغطيه كل ما تضمنته الجزيره
العربيه من فنون الى انظمه سياسيه
واقتصاديه وديانات وغيرها كل هذه هتدخل
ضمن المرويه لذلك شامل الجزيره العربيه
كامله الجزيره العربيه العرب اسمها
المرويه العربيه فلذلك اعتقد انه من
الضروري بانه يعني طبعا اقدم جزيل شكري
الحقيقه لقائمين على مركز فيصل على تبني
هذا الامر لكن اتمنى واناشد يعني
المسؤولين في وزاره الثقافه بوزاره
السياحه في وزاره التربيه والتعليم على او
التعليم ان نسيت اسمها التعليل
مع مركز الملك فيصل ابراز هذا الدوري
الحضاري للعرب هو في الحقيقه في خاتمه هذا
النقاش اريد ان تقول باختصار دكتور من
خلال دراستك انت لهذه الحضارات العربيه
القديمه حتى الحضارات الاسلاميه همم الان
الرؤيا همم صراحه ما نحتنا نفسا جديدا
وثقه جديده لانه نصت على ان السعوديه همم
يجب ان تستغل كونها ملتقى على الحضارات
حتى على مستوى الجسر البري همم الرابط بين
اسيا وافريقيا مستوى الاستقطاب الكفاءات
والكفايات الخارجيه همم هذا الامر اعتقد
انه انه علماء الاثار لهم دور كبير يجب ان
يقوموا فيه فهل ترى انهم قاموا به في
تعزيز هذا التنوع الحضاري او ايصاله للناس
يعني
قمنا فيه لانه صراحه صعب ونتركه
لا شك انه يجب علينا احنا انا في تصوري ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والجزيره
العربيه غنيه بالتراثها وغنيه باثارها
وغنيه بثقافتها وفي وانا عندي الحقيقه
دائما اقول وزاره الثقافه لها دور كبير
جدا لان اؤمن وزاره الثقافي وزاره
السلوكيه وهي لا تقل اهميه عندي من وزاره
الدفاع ولا وزاره الصحه ولا وزاره التعليم
بدون ان تكون هذه الوزاره الحقيقه تنتهي
همم ابراج السلوكيات الحقيقيه لمجتمع لن
نجد بالناس الاخيره من ابرز الاشياء هو
الانفتاح الاخر
احترام الاخر تقدير الاخر والايمان باننا
نحن في سفينه واحده لا يجب الحقيقه ان ان
ننظر للناس نظره غير طبيعيه وفي نفس الوقت
سلوكيات يجب ان تتحسن كما كان سلوكيات
اجدادنا الذين فتحوا بفكرهم النير وبفكر
منفتح قبل الاسلام بلدانا وزاروها وبنوا
ممالك فيها كل الممالك الساميه كانت
بقبائل عربيه هاجرت من الجزيره العربيه
لذلك وما هاجروا الفتره الاسلاميه الا
لانهم كانوا يتقبلون هذه الامور ويندم
يجون مع المجتمع في حدود في حدود
معتقداتهم
وهي خطوط حمراء
همم الحديث الذي لا اود ان ينتهي والحقيقه
انه لدينا لدينا انعاش ثقافيه همم مبشره
ان شاء الله وزاره الثقافه
جديد وعند هذا الحد انا اشكره كرامه حديثك
الذي تزامن مع مجيئك من بلد الكرم من حائل
بلد حاتم واشكركم انتم ايضا على كرم
المتابعه عند هذا الحديث الذي حقيقه لا
اود ان ينتهي لانه متشعب وله اثار
معاصره وصاينه نتحدث عن اثار القديمه لكن
له اثار معاصره يعرفها الحصص الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]